c'est une sacrée saisie qui risque de
faire trembler tous les narcotrafics en
france plus d'un million d'euros de
pilules d'ecstasy ont été saisis par la
police le 17 mars dernier à sainte foy
en région parisienne une prise sur
laquelle la police affirmant communiqué
sur twitter investigations fructueuse
des policiers qui ont jugulé à
saint-ouen un atelier de conditionnement
de produits stupéfiants
sauf que voilà quelques heures après les
résultats du laboratoire sont tombés et
ils sont formels cette poudreuse n'est
autre que de la poudre de fraises tagada
ni drogue ni transformation juste du
sucre et du colorant une grosse prise
qui n'a pas manqué de bien fait rire les
internautes pains
c'était sympa à sap oui moi je me
souviens d'une comédienne dont je tairai
le nom qui s'est retrouvé à l'hôpital
parce que sur un tournage avait confondu
à sa ligne et qui était supposée de la
cocaïne qui est en fait évidemment du
sucre en poudre et qu'elle as nous fait
une seconde poudre les cloisons
c'est en baston sur mon gâteau la masse
et la police des transports qui avait
suivi le gall j'étais tout content en
peluche et donc communiqué du coup ils
sont ridicules et pour horizon il est
obligés de relâcher leur soleure et
quand même ils vont le poursuivre pour
recel de 23 téléphone qu'il avait chez
lui
ridiculisés mais bon de toute façon le
mal est fait pour eux
tous